[Music]
of course i've seen you in the films and
you look like a jock but i understand
that you're you're quite into in school
you're quite into chemistry
you're a bit of a would you say it's
fair a science nerd a science nerd is
that fair i love science i do i love
science and math i'm very analytical i
think that's what right right brain left
brain
i don't know got to do the math on that
one but um you had me convinced until
you went like that
no but uh but you you like you like to
invent things i do i do i i fell in love
my my chemistry teacher mr mariner shout
out love you he uh he is the coolest
teacher i had and so in science class
i i fell in love with inventing just
because chemistry you
create and you put different atoms and
you you make chemical compounds together
and you just create stuff so i had an
invention book because he was the
awesome teacher and he said anything's
possible and i started
making stuff and like what did you make
like someone told me you made a device
that like a burglar who's trying to
escape the police could use
that was me i i okay i wanted to my
grandparents again are from iowa our
banks over there this is like before
video cameras or anything surveillance
cameras small little banks in the
country so as a kid i wanted to rob a
bank and i
i mean
this is absolutely fascinating i still
want to this is not where i thought this
interview would go
tell us more about your desire to commit
crime
it was more to get get away with it yeah
so i love cops
i love watching judge judy and cops and
rescue 9-1-1 and all these unsolved
mystery shows
and for me like i was like why don't the
guys getting chased from chased by the
cops have a trap door under the car like
you should plan ahead yeah because the
cameras only videotape when they're
throwing paraphernalia out the window
but if it was under the car there's no
cameras underneath right so my idea was
to rob a bank i would have my getaway
vehicle and then i'd go down an alleyway
and
in uh
cops chasing you stop chasing me there's
a it's a small alleyway so there's only
like one lead vehicle chasing me and
then the rest are underneath so i
created this i have all these drawings i
still want to do it i need like a
billion dollars so if anyone has that
that'd be great we got that we'll take
care of that so
let me let me just talk you through it
so it's like a pokemon ball right it
says red side yeah i watched pokemon or
i did um
and i'm obsessed with tesla tesla and
alberon sign and mishikaku so anyways
there's tesla coils in there and i have
a chemical compound and the whole idea
is when you push the pokemon ball
electrocutes itself you throw it under
your trapdoor so you're driving all cool
throw it under all cool take out your
pokemon balls pokemon ball
gotta catch em all right click it
you throw it out underneath the car
it's full electricity and once it hits
the lead vehicle like the metal it just
disrupts the whole battery and fries it
so when you stop the lead vehicle it
stops all the other cars because they
can't go around it so it just fries the
battery you can't restart the engine you
gave this a lot of thought on how to
foil the police when you when you rob a
bank yeah and do you think this could
actually work
yes